et le maire de la ville de jérusalem et
chez les hommes et ce n'est pas cette
leon le gouverneur de saint pétersbourg
monsieur alexandre b globe mail à
monsieur le président deux reines
revendre mais line le premier ministre
d'israël mais sur benyamin netanyahu et
son épouse madame sarah netanyahou n
enfin invité d'honneur le président de
la fédération de russie
monsieur vladimir poutine
[Musique]
et
oh
e
[Applaudissements]
bon
vous vous entendez ces leçons de mettre
un homme à l'époque pour les habitants
de leningrad
c'était le son le plus important parce
que ça permettrait de survivre pendant
les bombardements
mais quand ça a frappé plus vite ça va
signifier qu'il y avait des frappes des
bombardements pour la première fois ils
ont entendu ce sont le 8 septembre 1941
quand les troupes ont assiégé la ville
et ce jour là 2 millions habitants se
sont retrouvés dans cette ville assiégée
et c'était le début de ce siège qui va
durer a plus de 800 jours
la japonaise à bout du jeu suis pas ton
que sui toro trop la mise bas
[Musique]
à taza manque l'îlot loches parole et
puis je paye
[Musique]
un des souvenirs les pires pour des
survivants c'est le sentiment de la fin
les gens mangeaient seulement grâce à
des cartes de rationnement avec par
exemple 175 grammes de pain par jour et
les gens ajoutait du carton les gens
mangeaient de l'eab avec du sel les gens
mangeaient leurs ceintures avec un peu
de moutarde si l'on restait des gens
étaient prêts à vendre n'importe quoi
n'importe quel bijou vêtements pour
pouvoir acheter à manger et donc ce
sentiment de faim c'est le sentiment
propre au blocus c'est à dire manger le
pain jusqu'à la dernière miette
the night here is going to come
[Musique]
tamura cover de
slash non
oui
bon ok au bal
[Musique]
elle portait à vue
le froid
il n'y avait pas l'une des trolls n'y
avait pas de réchauffement à le système
d'alimentation à tout le marché vivan
que ce n'est pas le seul moyen de se
réchauffer a cité le métier qu'on ne
pouvait brûler tout ce qu'on pouvait
trouver les livres par exemple parquet
mais même cela n'était pas et vers
janvier
les gens ont fait face à un autre
problème le manque d'eau les gens
essayer de trouver de l'eau dans les
rivières à on faisait les trous dans la
glace et
novelli
justo violence ou jeu
parce que nous sommes
[Musique]
la seule voie de jonction entre
leningrad et le reste du pays c'était la
route de la vie et les véhicules avant
c'est le long de cette voie sur la glace
sur la route
il transportait des produits
d'alimentation et bien évidemment tout
cela n'était pas suffisant il a été
décidé d'évacuer une partie de la
population et on estime qu'ils sont à
peu près 500 millions de 500000
personnes à avoir été évacuée
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants
[Musique]
le jeu
trop la nique à bordeaux je n'aurai ni
gauche ne ment pas
houston c'est au beach club dispense
rien en somme
et malgré toutes les difficultés la
ville continuait de vivre de fonctionner
les gens produisent et les choses
nécessaires pour le fond et beaucoup de
travailleurs ne pouvait pas venir à
travail à cause de leur faiblesse et il
ne quittait pas leur lieu de travail
il dormait là mais malgré tout cela les
gens continuer de jouer au football
d'aller au théâtre concert
la ville a été libérée le 27 janvier
1944 la siège de leningrad c'était temps
des événements les plus terribles de
l'histoire de l'humanité
mais en même temps c'est l'un des
exemples le plus clair de du courage
joe ceux qui ont survécu et pour leurs
enfants me sont aujourd'hui ici à
jérusalem pour inaugurer le monument le
budget de le même voire à nommage où
nous habitants et défenseurs de la gra
assiégée
commune
bon
oh
[Musique]
et
jeumont
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
total rina maximilien mesdames messieurs
les intrigues f
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président de la fédération
de russie vladimir poutine bienvenue à
jérusalem mais sur robben rivlin
président d'israël
chers amis monsieur le premier ministre
binyamin netanyahu et son épouse sarah
netanyahu monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères de la fédération de
russie monsieur lavrov
monsieur le gouverneur de saint
pétersbourg monsieur big love chers
ministres chers députés de la knesset
d'honneur et participants à
l'inauguration du monument en l'honneur
des soldats de l'armée rouge et des
défenseurs de la ville de leningrad lors
de son blocus chers amis aujourd'hui la
journée d'aujourd'hui me réjouis et en
même temps elle suscite chez moi une
grande émotion émotion car les malheurs
de l'humanité qui ont été ceux du passé
les gens qui ont lutté contre le froid
contre la faim contre la mort sont
aujourd'hui honoré en tant que héros
certains d'entre eux sont présents
aujourd'hui figure parmi nos invités aux
côtés du président de la fédération
russe
ici à jérusalem la capitale de l'état
d'israël l'honneur et la mémoire de ceux
qui sont tombés pendant cette guerre
vous qui avait connu ces jours là qui
avait connu ce blocus qui avait subi
cette agression nazi qui a duré huit
cent soixante douze jours qui a été une
manifestation du mal contre l'humanité
et qui a frappé les habitants de la
ville de leningrad
avec plus d'un million de personnes
femmes et enfants qui sont morts de faim
dans la ville de leningrad vos parents
mais monsieur le président poutine était
justement parmi ces gens qui ont subi ce
blocus et je sais que votre père a
combattu qu'il a été blessé
et c'est avec une grande douleur qu'ils
ont perdu leur fils victor votre frère
jérusalem c'est ce qu'est un blocus
il y à plus de 2500 ans jérusalem
avaient subi le premier grand blocus qui
avait abouti à la destruction du temple
et israël avait reperdu son indépendance
sa liberté et était parti en exode
la description des malheurs subis par la
population du blocus et quand nous
parlons d horreur des terreurs de la fin
nous avons du mal à comprendre tout à
fait ce qu'est cette souffrance mais les
prophètes d'israël
appelez les meilleurs soldats du pays à
prendre les armes
pour lutter mais c'était aussi la lutte
contre la faim et à leningrad la
poétesse russe anna akhmatova avait
aussi écrit des vers où il était
question du pain qui est l'essentiel la
préoccupation essentielle qui
représentait ce cri qui sortait des
bouches vers le ciel et là encore et
l'héroïsme de peuples qui a supporté
cette épreuve et qui a su ne pas faiblir
chers amis monsieur le président poutine
la guerre à lier nos peuples c'est un
lien inextricable entre nos deux peuples
les envahisseurs nazis souhaitait
détruire leningrad et l'armée rouge et
les défenseurs de la ville ont été
héroïques à défendre la ville les
envahissants des envahisseurs nazis
souhaitait détruire le peuple juif et
l'armée rouge à libérer les prisonniers
des camps d'auschwitz et des autres
camps et elle a aidé les réfugiés juifs
qui étaient disséminés en europe
dans quatre jours le 27 janvier nous
célébrons le 75e anniversaire de la
libération de leningrad et le même jour
ne célébreront la mémoire des victimes
de l'holocauste
et ce sera le 75e anniversaire de la
libération des camps de la mort
dershowitz birkenau
et parmi les six millions de juifs qui
ont été déporté en camp
beaucoup d'entre eux venaient delà de
l'été de famille de beaucoup de pays est
aujourd'hui des ans des représentants de
ma famille mon arrière grand mère et son
fils michael sont morts à auschwitz
ils n'ont pas pu survivre et je leur dis
regardez c'est la restauration de la
mémoire
nous nous trouvons ici aujourd'hui à
jérusalem qui est la capitale d'israël
avec le président de la fédération de
russie et nos héros du passé et du fond
du coeur
nous vous disons merci merci au nom de
la vie de jason l'année au nom de
l'ensemble du peuple juif et au nom de
ceux qui ont réussi à survivre à cette
horreur grâce à l'armée rouge
merci d'avoir mis fin à cette horreur
aujourd'hui nous inaugurons le monument
consacré aux défenseurs de la ville de
leningrad
il a été construit partiellement à saint
pétersbourg est en partie à jérusalem
est ce monument réuni des éléments du
passé et de l'avenir
c'est un monument de mémoire c'est un
monument à l'héroïsme et c'est un
monument à l'espoir de l'humanité
ce monument célèbre donc là mais moi
aussi des juifs qui sont morts pendant
le blocus de leningrad et aujourd'hui et
ça c'est à saint pétersbourg est
aujourd'hui si à jérusalem nous ouvrons
ce monument à la mémoire des personnes
qui ont subi le blocus dos c'est donc un
monument double et commun et j'affirme
avec conviction fortement clairement
[Musique]
plus jamais ça l'union pacific entre la
russie et le peuple juif entre jérusalem
et saint pétersbourg existera toujours
vive la mémoire de ceux qui sont tombés
merci c'était la merde
m maintenant je voudrais en veut-elle
partenaires qui ont contribué à
construire ce monument pour l'inaugurer
j'ai envie de le président du congrès
juif
karine sol mais ce dernier l'a tard le
président de la fondation internationale
juifs
[Musique]
monsieur michael mirage suivi le
président des fondations renault là
monsieur vekselberg
le président du congrès juif lui sur you
wake and bear est l'initiateur de ce
projet mais sur les téléskis
les tignasses coeur
je te fais make-up dubaï alors messieurs
on ouvre notre monument
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs maintenant nous
allons inaugurer notre monument
j'invite le ministre pour les affaires
de jérusalem
le maire de jérusalem sur les ondes avec
son épouse
le gouverneur de saint pétersbourg
monsieur alexandre bègue love le premier
ministre d'israël monsieur netanyahu et
son épouse madame sarah netanyahu le
président de la fédération de russie
monsieur poutine
[Musique]
monsieur le président messieurs poutine
on vous demande d'inaugurer ce monument
[Musique]
et maintenant nous invitons les
participants à la cérémonie
vous pouvez prendre une photo ce
monument est le résultat de la
coopération à trois des architectes
russes et israéliens l'auteur du
monument et 8 mètres et demi
[Musique]
l'élément central et de ce monument est
un tel acquis 13 euros et qui ait ce
genre du mouvement existe depuis
l'époque
depuis très longtemps et vous pouvez
voir les symboles de la ville de
saint-pétersbourg de l'état d'israël sur
ce monument
ce sont des décorations de ce monument
il y à des écritures en trois langues en
hébreu en russe et un anglais sur ce
monument au centre de ce monument vous
voyez les décorations qui au soir
ressemble à une bougie et à l'intérieur
de ce monument aider à des capteurs qui
réagissent chaque fois quand quelqu'un
s'approche de ce monument et qui vont
imiter le son du métronome
je remercie tout le monde est maintenant
vous pouvez prendre vos places à
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs je demande à tous les
participants à la cérémonie de prendre
leur place
mesdames messieurs nous voudrions tour
sur notre cérémonie
et je répète je vous demande de couper
vos places
[Musique]
il a lutté contre le nazisme et ensuite
il a participé à la formation des jeunes
générations et je tiens invité monsieur
abraham zenden qui était le président de
l'association des anciens combattants de
la seconde guerre mondiale en israël
abri êtes vous êtes attendus sur la
scène
veuillez l'applaudir c'est émouvant
je suis très ému arrêtez vous un instant
s'il vous plaît réfléchissez en 2020
après soit 75 ans après la victoire sur
le nazisme sur la terre sainte d'israël
dans la capitale jérusalem au coeur de
trois religions le très vénéré président
de la fédération de russie vladimir
poutine le président israélien
monsieur rivlin le premier ministre
netanyahu des députés de la knesset
les représentants des deux pays des
représentants
2 du blocus de la guerre de bp sont ici
pour ouvrir ce monument en hommage aux
survivants du blocus et à ceux qui ont
lutté et aux soldats de l'armée rouge
qui en perdant la vie en mourant de faim
de froid qui ont travaillé dans les
usines à saint peter's à leningrad et
qui pour quelques miettes de pain et ont
lutté et n'ont pas toujours su survivre
donc hommage à tous ceux qui ont tenu
jusqu'à jusqu'au jour de la victoire
hommage à tous ces enfants qui ont su
survivre et transmettre cet héritage
cet héritage aujourd'hui ils sont avec
nous comme leurs pères leurs frères
leurs grands pères qui ont été au combat
c'est notre souvenir c'est notre mémoire
cher ami cher monsieur le président de
fédération de russie
c'est une page importante de notre
histoire qui nous oblige à continuer à
vivre avec espoir et compréhension
mutuelle
odieux bonnes gens le coeur ouvert en
geste de gratitude pour les générations
qui nous ont précédés qui ont subi cette
guerre horrible
rendons hommage à ceux qui ont contribué
aujourd'hui à l'érection de ce monument
tout d'abord représentants du congrès
juif mondial à monsieur le président du
congrès juif de russie et au fonds
national d'entre aide pour les juifs à
vous chers amis notre gratitude et notre
reconnaissance de soldats que le chemin
que vous avez suivi avec nos peuples
soient toujours marquée par de bonnes
actions nous vous sommes reconnaissants
pour la contribution que vous avez
apporté lycée et la direction
l'administration de jérusalem les deux
saint pétersbourg les députés qui ont
participé les différents comités qui ont
participé à la préparation de cette
cérémonie qui ont été les initiateurs de
cette idée au niveau de saint
pétersbourg et au niveau de jérusalem
merci à vous chers amis qui est ici
présents chers camarades de combat
nous avons élevé ce monument d'hommage
mais nous avons réuni tout ce qui
se rapporte à la mémoire des juifs qui
ont qui sont dans nos mémoires
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous unis ce
grand monument que nous venons
d'inaugurer aujourd'hui doit nous
permettre de nous souvenir des années
passées plus jamais ça
garder la mémoire garder la paix conseil
des chansons les signal est devenue
symbole pour les combattants russes et
jean vite
la chanteuse russe tatiana pavlovsk aia
et le chanteur david d'abord
[Musique]
mieux encore bravo je pense au score ni
pires ni meilleurs rôles et nip sierre
mello bra revenir qu'à toi
[Musique]
il
oui ça
un bon
[Musique]
mismari une formule 1
je vous
m
tu as eue
[Musique]
du coup
mais
et
[Musique]
il
aucune
b
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
je m'ouvre
je souris
tu
[Musique]
des chemins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tatiana parle lorsque ier et
david
[Musique]
je voudrais inviter monsieur reuven
rivlin cher président de la fédération
de russie monsieur vladimir poutine
monsieur le premier ministre vous n'êtes
minami netanyahu et son épouse
monsieur le maire de jérusalem
monsieur le gouverneur de saint
pétersbourg messieurs les ministres
députés de la knesset représentants des
ambassades l'ouverture l'inauguration de
ce monument
chers amis monsieur le président donc
cette inauguration
je dirais que un des moments où j'étais
les plus émues dans ma vie c'est quand
j'étais près du monument des défenseurs
de du blocus de leningrad ce blocus qui
avait duré presque 900 jours 900 jours
pendant lesquels la ville de leningrad a
été assiégé 900 jours pendant lesquels
toute la ville a été a fait l'objet des
attaques incessantes de bombardement de
la part des des envahisseurs nazis 900
jours pendant lesquels
des millions d'enfants de femmes de
personnes âgées deux soldats sont morts
morts de faim de froid et qui ont
apporté leur vie en sacrifice pour
sauver leur ville leur patrie cette
guerre jusque jusqu'à la dernière goutte
de sang jusqu'à la dernière miette de
pain a été l'objet de leur lutte pour
survivre
les habitants de leningrad
on vous le voir la lumière triompher des
ténèbres voir l'esprit triomphait des
souffrances matériels et corporels pour
voir le sentiment de victoire
et quand nous voyons aujourd'hui à
jérusalem en ce mois de janvier nous
l'état d'israël
nous avons du mal à imaginer ce froid
terrible dans lequel les gens ont
souffert dans en janvier 2 en janvier
1942 à leningrad
ceux qui ont survécu à ce blocus ont dit
que ç'avait été l'hiver le plus terrible
de cette guerre et effectivement ce
premier revers du blocus avait été
particulièrement rude
après que les entrepôts de nourriture
ont été bombardés dans la ville de
leningrad
ap au bout de quatre mois quand la
population n'avait reçu aucune aide
aucun aliment aucune denrée alimentaire
aucun médicament et il y avait cet hiver
septentrionale avec ses ce gel terrible
jusqu'à -30
sans chauffage sans nourriture sans
possibilité de fuir la population était
réduite à s'est réduite avait été
réduite à manger cette faible ration de
pain 125 grammes pour ceux qui ne
travaillaient pas dans son sac à main
pour ceux qui travaillent et et les gens
ont tenu l'esprit de résistance de
leningrad a tenu et la population a
refusé de se rendre
la mère patrie ruche n'avait pas la
décision de se rendre au contraire il
fallait résister et il n'y avait il n'y
a pas de plus grand amour que l'amour
maternel et c'est ce que la mère patrie
russe a manifesté à l'égard de ses fils
de ses filles qui menait ce combat de
tous les jours et c'est un acte
d'héroïsme de patriotisme qui était
essentielle et le 27 janvier 1944 il y à
76 ans exactement
le blocus a été levé
et ce n'est pas un hasard parce que le
27 janvier
c'est aussi une date symbolique pour
notre histoire commune
car le 27 janvier 1945 les soldats de
l'armée rouge ont libéré les camps de la
mort 2 d'ocz ritz et cette date est
maintenant célébrée dans l'ensemble du
monde comme journée d'hommage aux
victimes de l'holocauste
donc c'est une fête que nous célébrons
les larmes aux yeux
parce que c'est une fête qui est quand
même une fête de victoire c'est la
victoire de l'esprit de force
monsieur le président poutine vous êtes
né dans cette ville de leningrad j'ai vu
la maison les meubles dans lequel vous
êtes né et j'ai vu ces lieux j'ai vu les
grands pères les grands mères j'ai vu
les représentants de cette ville de
vaillants cette ville de courage cette
ville de mémoire et qui gardera toujours
cette mémoire cette mémoire la mémoire
de ses fils et l'état d'israël conserve
la mémoire de cette deuxième guerre
mondiale qui est quasiment synonyme de
l'holocauste au cours duquel six
millions de représentants du peuple juif
sont morts et c'est une blessure ouverte
qui ne va jamais cicatrisées et la
connaissance de l'histoire la
connaissance de ces événements qui nous
montre la voie en tant que peuple en
tant que nation est aujourd'hui ici sont
présents avec le maire de la ville
nous avons la possibilité de rendre
hommage aux habitants de l'union
soviétique de l'ancienne union
soviétique
aujourd'hui avec nous et des soldats qui
ont combattu sur le front de l'est et
pour cela pour l'état d'israël d'israël
c'est une date importante et l'hommage
que nous rendons aux soldats de l'armée
rouge
c'est considérable pour beaucoup de
juifs la russie et l'ancienne urss sont
le symbole de cette lutte contre le
nazisme contre le fascisme contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme la haine et cela
en pleine au coeur et cette lutte cette
éducation que nous apportons à toutes
les générations
monsieur le président nous tenons à
cette union sacrée entre nos peuples et
c'est pour nous tous un grand honneur
d'être ici dans la capitale d'israël et
d'inaugurer ensemble ce monument
consacré à la mémoire de ceux qui ont
lutté et de leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui sont présents avec nous des
immigrés de l'union soviétique danse des
anciens combattants des gens qui ont
connu les horreurs de cette guerre et
c'est une occasion de plus pour nous
monsieur le premier ministre de l'état
d'israël de rendre hommage à toutes ces
familles à tous ses représentants à tous
ceux qui ont fait preuve de vaillance de
résistance et d'avoir tenu d'avoir
supporter l'horreur de cette machine
nazie et grâce à ce monument aujourd'hui
que nous avons que nous venons
d'inaugurer que nous venons d'inaugurer
nous avons la possibilité de garder nos
coeurs tourner vers l'avenir pour le
bien de nos générations soyez bénis
[Musique]
le président de la fédération de russie
mon ami l'a dit mir poutine le président
d'israël révèle une rêverie
bonjour mais le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
le gouverneur de saint pétersbourg
alexandre belov maire de jérusalem
monsieur léon et son épouse à messieurs
le ministre vice ministres représentant
de la knesset
les représentants de l'union des anciens
combattants
je vous salue parce que vous soutenez
cette mémoire ces flammes boulot qui
vaut toujours existé chers partenaires
qui ont créé ce monument cher architect
je voudrais vous saluer également ainsi
que les gens qui ont travaillé avec leur
coeur pour le créer ici nous souvenons
de ce qui s'est passé à leningrad
nous honorons la mémoire de ceux qui
sont morts dans cette guerre et ce
monument il y à des écritures en trois
langues
en russie un hébreu en anglais
il y à des écritures sur ce monument qui
parle de lui-même c'est l'amour pour la
patrie c'est la lutte à fond de
d'attendre la victoire la victoire
contre les nazis
[Musique]
cette victoire contre les nazis
malgré que nous avons gagné nous devons
comprendre que les victimes étaient
énormes
presque un million de gens sont morts à
leningrad uniquement et en russie en
l'ancien ans l'ancienne union soviétique
environ 27 millions de personnes sont
tombées pendant cette guerre nous ne
devons pas oublier l'aide le soutien de
l'union soviétique
des soldats et des officiers de l'armée
rouge qui ont mis fin à cette machine
nazie et qui ont sauvé notre monde face
à cette tragédie énorme
nous ressentons toujours cette douleur
nous avons des blessures et des
cicatrices nous avons perdu nos proches
vous avez dit monsieur le maire que
jérusalem a subi beaucoup de blocus et
vous avez décrit en des blocus mais cinq
cents ans plus tard un historien a dit
cris le blocus de jérusalem par eux les
l'as rome et des centaines de milliers
de gens sont morts dans ce blocus
les gens sont morts de faim les gens ont
fait des choses horribles
lisez le et vous allez voir jérusalem a
connu des blocus terrible tout comme
d'autres villes du monde mais parmi tous
ces blocus la siège de leningrad c'est
l'événement le plus terrible
les nazis voulaient détruire cette ville
détruire tout le monde éliminer cette
ville les souffrances étaient énormes on
récente et la mort dans chaque maison
nous avons parlé avec monsieur poutine
nous en parler de son père de sa maison
son père qui a lutté
nous allons parler de sa famille qui a
perdu le frère de monsieur le président
victor et monsieur poutine n'a jamais vu
son frère victor qui est mort dans le
blocus je sais très bien ce que c'est de
perdre de perdre un frère père en fils
je le connais très bien et cette période
a duré presque 900 jours période de la
mort ma le monde entier aveu que le
courage et l'héroïsme vont toujours
vaincre et les gens n'ont jamais perdu
l'espoir malgré le froid malgré la fin
les gens continuent et de quoi y est les
soldes à continuer de lutter jusqu à
mort jusqu'à la fin et parmi ses soldats
il ya vis des représentants de notre
peuple
il ya des gens qui peuvent raconter
beaucoup d'histoires aujourd'hui j'ai
entendu une nouvelle histoire j'ai parlé
avec en des anciens combattants qui
aujourd'hui habite un israël le sérail
céline à la 95 ans elle habite à israël
et raïssa à l'âge de 17 ans elle est
devenue médecin est allé en crade et
face
à ces circonstances terribles l aider
les gens qui perdaient leurs jambes
elle n'avait que 250 g de pain par jour
elle devait travailler dans ces
conditions
et aujourd'hui à israël les jeunes gens
écoutent les histoires de right side
autres anciens combattants y longtemps
cette histoire et il regarde avec fierté
les médailles de raïssa et quand moi
quand je vois vos médailles les méthodes
des anciens combattants je vous rend
honneur je vous rends hommage les
histoires des anciens combattants sont
incroyables votre courage pendant les
combats à moscou à berlin en europe à
stalingrad votre courage a mené à cette
victoire face à la machine nazie
monsieur le président il ya 18 mois je
suis participer au défilé sur la place
rouge à moscou
et pour moi c'était dans mon très
émouvant et j'ai vu les anciens
combattants on a honoré la mémoire des
ics ont pris des juifs qui ont sacrifié
leur vie pour sauver l'humanité
et dans quelques heures nous allons nous
réunir dans le complexe mémorial sis à
israël pour honorer la libération
d'auschwitz et il faut se souvenir que
c'est l'armée rouge qui a sauvé les
prisonniers d'auschwitz et maintenant 75
plus tard nous avons
décidée il peut y avoir de compromis
avec les tyrans qui sont pour
l'idéologie de la mort il faut mettre
fin à cette idéologie à l'époque de
l'holocauste et m nous non
il n'y avait pas d'état d'israël
maintenant nous avons notre état c'est
un médecin très fort et ceux qui veulent
le détruire vont faire face à une
réaction de notre état mais cette menace
existe non uniquement pour nous mais
pour le monde entier
nous devons nous réunir sur le fond
international afin de défendre notre
sécurité et notre existence
ensemble nous allons nous protéger nous
allons mettre fin à cette menace nous
allons faire tout pour créer notre avis
niort comment il y a huit ans nous avons
inauguré un monument consacré à la lutte
contre les nazis
et maintenant nous avons un moment de
plus qui est au degré aujourd'hui c'est
une bougie qui symbolise la victoire de
la lumière et je suis reconnaissant à
tous ceux qui ont contribué à ce
monument
aujourd'hui tous les gens qui sont ici
dans ce parc pouvons voir ce monument et
nous allons voir la joie des enfants
nous avons parlé à penser à cela quand
nous avons créé ce monument parce que
pour nous ce qui est important c'est de
protéger la vie merci merci c'était le
premier ministre d'israël monsieur
netanyahou la tragédie
delahaye en grade c'était une tragédie
et également pour la famille de monsieur
poutine chaque année monsieur poutine se
rend dans les lieux de blocus ces gens
vite monsieur le président vladimir
poutine chers anciens combattants
monsieur le président messieurs premier
ministre son épouse
monsieur le maire son épouse chers amis
c'est pour moi un grand honneur d'être
ici à l'inauguration de ce monument
dédié à l'exploit est à la mémoire des
personnes qui ont subi le blocus de
leningrad
cela est important non seulement pour
les gens de notre pays mais aussi pour
ceux de nos deux pays et il ya soixante
seize ans s'est achevée une des pages
les plus tragiques de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est la levée du blocus de leningrad et
comme nos collègues l'ont dit donc un an
plus tard le 27 janvier 1945 l'armée
rouge a libéré le plus grand camp de la
mort nazi en l'occurrence celui
d'auschwitz et cela est devenu la date
de commémoration chaque année des
victimes de l'holocauste
autant d'exploits de souffrance dans
cette tragédie humaine
mais le blocus de leningrad et le low
cost ne peuvent être comparés à rien
d'autre
et au cours des générations nous
transmettons la mémoire et l'hommage à
ces millions de morts ces gens qui ont
manifesté l'héroïsme dans les privations
et notre colère juste commune est
engagée contre ce qu ont commis les
nazis
l'abnégation de ceux qui ont lutté
contre cette horreur fait l'objet de
notre hommage cela est bien sûr
manifesté dans des documents mais aucun
document aucun récit aucune chronique
cinématographique ou autre ne peut
témoigner en totalité de ceux qui ont
supporté les victimes
et comme ça a été dit mon père a
participé à la défense de la ville ma
mère était dans la ville assiégée
elle a perdu son père en 1942 dans
l'hiver et qui a été enterré au
cimetière puisque hariolf comme des
centaines de milliers d'autres citoyens
tout cela ce ne sont pas des paroles en
l'air pour moi et donc ces gens qui ont
été condamnés à mourir de faim et cette
ville qui est et qui devait être
bombardées et qu'il a été constamment
constamment depuis le sol depuis les
airs tout cela a été fixée
fx et dans des documents mais les
habitants de leningrad quelle que soit
leur nationalité n'ont pas cédé malgré
les combats qui se continuer ils ont
continué à faire fonctionner les usines
ils se sont battus ils ont continué à
fournir des armes
j'ai parlé d'armement l'instant moi je
savais pas et j'ai les su il ya quelques
jours en consultant des documents
d'archivés
c'est que durant les années du blocus de
leningrad
dans cette situation la ville a fourni
cent quarante mille tonnes de sens pour
le front cette population privée de
nourriture de lumière de chaleur n'a pas
cessé de produire de faire des
recherches scientifiques de travailler
pour les générations à venir
tout cela est devenu légende mais c'est
grâce aux exploits de l'esprit de la
force d'esprit et la mémoire que nous le
monument que nous avons inauguré
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le monument
de notre mémoire en commun et les
représentants de la communauté
israélienne de nos compatriotes des
anciens combattants tout cela personne
ne peut rester indifférent indifférence
là il ya eu un investissement financier
et je tiens à exprimer notre gratitude à
l'état d'israël de voir sans sa
contribution pour rendre hommage à ceux
qui ont souffert en u à 16 pendant la
guerre
nous voyons aujourd'hui des tentatives
de nier l'holocauste dernier cette
tragédie
mais aujourd'hui nous voyons que c'est
le deuxième monument comme l'a dit le
président il serait bien qui a été
inauguré ces dernières années donc vous
voyez un nous voyons le premier avait
été ouvert et n'augure et anna thani et
et cette attitude
dommage de la part de nos amis
israéliens pour les soldats de l'armée
rouge
tout cela est important que cela va
aussi en lien avec eux le mémorial de
yad vashem et chaque année le 22 juin
qui est le jour de la dune qui
correspond au premier jour de
l'agression nazie contre la russie et
chaque année nous allumant des bougies
en l'honneur des victimes de cette
guerre
cette tradition avait a commencé en 2008
à saint pétersbourg est ici nous avons
aussi justement une bougie de mémoire
qui a été allumé
ici dans ce pays où vivent beaucoup de
d'anciens combattants de cette guerre au
nombre de 4000 et ici comme en russie on
connaît l'importance des leçons du passé
et nous ne permettrons pas que le monde
oublie ce sacrifice
cette douleur et ne permettront pas la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme de
chauvinisme etc
et c'est une leçon pour les générations
qu'ils vont nous suivre et c'est un
hommage ce monument en fait un hommage à
ceux qui nous ont offert la vie qui nous
ont permis de survivre
pour conclure je voudrais ajouter encore
quelques mots un monument c'est
évidemment quelque chose de bien
ça restera pour longtemps et j'espère
pour le siècle et on peut inaugurer un
monument de façon diverse mais comme
vous l'a fait aujourd'hui c'est
important merci c'était le président de
la fédération de russie vladimir poutine
[Applaudissements]
après la libération de la ville de
leningrad le vent c'est janvier 1904
[Musique]
l'artillerie a attiré pour symboliser la
fin de sept sièges et le david toute
manoeuvre a écrit un chanson qui est
devenue symbolique et vassili guerre est
là et le corps des anciens combattants
d'israël vont chanter pour vous cette
chanson vraiment symbolique
[Musique]
t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
allez
non
à
[Musique]
et
je
léa est là
voilà
[Musique]
à
comment ce match il est sous munitions
nous préciserons est très apprécié
[Musique]
mais je n'ai
ici
[Musique]
c'est du flan
allez-y
[Musique]
c
oh
mais
il y a
[Musique]
c'est
vive la victoire nous sommes déjà tous
debout et je propose de chanter les in
de deux pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
radi ligne hatikva
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nicole les erreurs c'était la cérémonie
d'inauguration du monument consacré ou
combattants et aux défenseurs